in this episode of X X Files if we can
gain a glimpse of what their health
status is just by taking a small piece
of skin and looking at these microbes
then that may aid our understanding of
their health and ultimately that's what
we need for their conservation that's
great well that's a couple up here
little dolphin
oh here you
whoo
my name is Amy April and I'm an
assistant scientist at the woods hole
oceanographic institution I've been
studying the skin microbiome of the
humpbacks for several years now and
we've started to pick up part some
trends in this microbiome microbiome is
basically just an assemblage of
microorganisms these are mostly single
cells that live in association with a
marine animal we've been able to look at
several health compromised whales those
have either been stranded on beaches are
entangled in fishing line and what we
found is that their microbiome is
shifted compared to the healthy animals
and so they don't have these same what
we think are potentially helpful groups
of bacteria on their skin and these
health compromised animals also have
started to develop relationship with
potential pathogens so if we can gain a
glimpse of what their health status is
just by taking a small piece of skin and
looking at these microbes then that may
aid our understanding of their health
and ultimately that's what we need for
their conservation we're going to look
at the microbes in it two different ways
one way as we look at who the microbes
are using their DNA as well as look at
where the microbes are under the
microscope it's been really exciting to
bring this new way of looking at the
microbiome
community of marine mammal scientists
that are already so invested in learning
more about the health of these animals
and the measures that are needed to
conserve the species I'm working with
Duke Robins who's a senior scientist at
the Provincetown Center for coastal
studies Jukes been fantastic and getting
us skin samples that we can take into my
lab and start to analyze and look at at
the microbes QCOM David
that might have been a dive which means
we may not see him for a few minutes
yesterday we were out on the tip of Cape
Cod chasing humpback whales and we were
lucky enough to obtain a skin biopsy
sample from one of these humpback whales
we then spend a little bit of time
cleaning up the samples and then we send
them off to a sequencing facility
usually within a couple weeks we receive
our data back the sequence data that we
get back is just letters this is the DNA
code in every sample that we've looked
at from basically around the world we
find two main groups of bacteria the
Tanach evac you limb genus and the
psycho factored this is a really
powerful finding that we find whales and
living in really different ocean
environments that have the same types of
bacteria on their skin and then whales
do this other thing that I think is
really cool is that they shed their skin
pretty frequently and so they're
constantly somehow reviving that
population of microbes we think there
must be some other type of mechanism
that allows these cells to maintain
residents on the skin surface the whale
skin is so complex and that there are so
many cells there that it's really
challenging to pick apart what is a
microbial cell so the way that we're
going about that is we're using a DNA
strand that's specific for bacteria and
it has a fluorescent tag on the end and
we add that to these little thin
sections and allow it to sit overnight
and then what we'll do is look at it
under the microscope and where we see
that fluorescent tag should correspond
to where the bacterial cells are
oh yeah there's the edge oh that's cool
so here we're looking at the surface of
the skin layer and under the microscope
we see the structure of the skin in
white here in contrast to the black
where there's no sample what we're
looking for some bright spots were our
probe in we do see a few of those on the
surface right in that area yeah there's
another chain cells over there and
potentially some deeper as well once we
look at more samples will be able to
form a better understanding of how these
cells are associating with the whale
skin so we've been following this
juvenile humpback whale for several
minutes now and thus far we don't
recognize it as a whale that we've
cataloged before nor as a whale that we
biopsy sample before and that's why it's
important for us to get a sample today
to apply to a number of different
studies jen is poised with the dart
biopsy and what Jen's going to be doing
here is hopefully when the whale comes
up to the surface and the boat is at the
right angle and close enough to the
animal jen is going to release that dart
and get a skin biopsy from from the
whale
right
this work done it's like a sample a dart
has a float that will let it remain at
the surface until we're able to pick it
up with the net being able to scale up
from from this relationship that we're
studying in the lab to actually seeing
these animals in the wild is really
important we're also interested in
expanding our studies to more species of
marine mammal so we decided about 16
species thus far and there's about a
hundred and twenty nine species of
marine mammals out there
we're finding new kinds of life every
day and these micro biomes and marine
mammals haven't been studied in capacity
in the past and so it's allowing us to
discover a new relationship I can't
believe how many new collaborations I've
been able to spend up just in the last
few years and so I think this is a
really good sign and a promise that
we're going to be able to continue this
research what does it come that sound
like
it's a blow but with Lauren and applied
it in a bit of
this home a little bit of Tony
not quite like an elephant yes
oh my heard that trumpet
been shown that dogs can actually detect
cancer what we're doing is we're trying
to use dogs to help us determine what
volatile biomarkers are associated with
ovarian cancer